[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof hello
Maron hello Walter hi uh our students
asked me to ask you how you
doing are you serious yes
all of them yes but they see me every
day they should be knowing how I'm doing
they think that maybe if I ask you
you'll give a a different answer maybe
you'll get an honest answer I'm terribly
sorry to disappoint
them no they they really enjoying the
classes so so Martin what are we talking
about
today gold gold Golden Age golden cards
golden domes everything has to do with
gold but you can you please just
Enlighten us who was the king of that
was golden in past history well you're
talking about Nebuchadnezzar who had
commissioned the statue of gold
representing the Babylonian Empire and
saying May It Last Forever mhm it's
interesting Martin that it was then and
the Bible says it will be there in the
end yeah so maybe maybe the adversary
managed to make Make It Last Forever
well and the consequences that happened
there I think uh the Bible says will
happen again to the final one as well
well let's have a look but we better
pray before we start pray let's pray our
heavenly father we are living in
momentous times we thank you for for
that but with that comes great
responsibility and we ask that you help
us to discern through all the quack mire
out there and now that we do this
discussion please enlighten our minds
that we can do it to honor your name in
Jesus name amen
amen well a golden age but the Bible
says there will be a form of tyranny In
The End by compelling consciences right
yeah and uh golden age for America I see
the Statue of Liberty is gold from top
to bottom there
Martin wear the arms of silver and
brass and iron and iron and
Clay so I think this is the this is the
the image that when you hear the sound
of the timbral and the all of those you
will bow down you know of course that
the Statue of Liberty is actually a
statue of Mitra you can explain a little
bit Yeah the sun god well we've done
that yeah yeah it comes from the Age of
Reason yes well let's jump right into
this and see where we go
but Martin Gaza doesn't even exist in
this form yet it's just a in a rubble
form at the moment yeah well so is this
a a sort of an emblem of what the whole
world can look like in a millennium of
Peace that's what they would like it to
be okay but is that what the Bible says
well let's have a look America is back
there should be a comma there otherwise
you could read it America is back
posted in other words it's taken a step
backwards right well in some form maybe
yes but if you put a comma there it's
very important where you put the comma
isn't it the utmost importance America
is
back posted on
X all right let's have a look what this
is all about
it has only been 44 days but the
president will have a lot to talk about
tonight when he heads up to Capitol Hill
to address a joint 6 weeks ago I stood
beneath the Dome of this capital and
proclaimed the dawn of the golden age as
inaugurate a new president and vice
president from that moment on it has
been nothing but Swift and unrelenting
action to usher in the greatest and most
successful era in the history of our
country I returned to this chamber
tonight to
report that America's momentum is
back our spirit is
back Bri's
B members of Congress and to my fellow
citizens
America is back
Americans have given us a mandate for
bold and profound change every day my
Administration is fighting to bring a
future that America deserves we are
draining the Swap and the days of ruled
by unelected bureaucrats are
over over the past 6 weeks I have signed
nearly 100 executive orders and taking
more than 400 executive actions to
restore Common Sense saf
optimism and wealth all across our
wonderful
land despite the best efforts of those
who try to censor us silence us break us
destroy us Americans are today a proud
free Sovereign and independent nation
that will always be free my fellow
Americans get ready for an incredible
future because the Golden Age of America
has only just begun thank you God bless
you and God bless
[Music]
[Applause]
America well mtin what's very
interesting is that this was posted by
the government yes the White House on
his and the other Twitter u x account
okay now what's interesting is how they
interchange between the promise of a
golden age and the constant military jet
flyovers indicating American might right
yeah yeah is that something that you
would be able to relate to the second
beast of Revelation chapter 13 for sure
one that has the power to dictate to the
whole world because if the religious
system wants to it to be dictated it
can't do it on its own it needs somebody
to do it for them remember that the
Chinese just recently announced that if
America wants a trade war or any other
War they're ready for
them but uh I see they quickly
backtracked on that one very
quickly uh when this second beast
becomes
prescriptive then it seems that the
others are somewhat in
disarray for at the in the beginning
it's like zalinski when he went to the
office he was quite full of
bravado he was put in his place very
quickly now he's not that yeah you know
he was used to being this uh favorite
Ally and now he gets
reprimanded and that put shock waves
amongst the
pigeons so it's all very interesting so
so is he stepping up to the plate here
is he speaking oh for sure a golden age
Martin isn't that sound almost new age
yes oh definitely that's very new age
terminology isn't that the same language
that latki and Bailey uses all of them
use that
language so is it possible that we have
an integration here because remember
that blavatsky and Alice a
Bailey said that there will be no peace
unless there is an
integration of the esoteric world and
the religious world everybody has to
come to the same point there must be no
distinction between the esoteric world
and the religious World well that is
amazing because that's what's happening
that's exactly what's happening right
people just don't know that Christianity
has moved so far from the original
intent that now it has moved into a
direction where it's almost like uh an
esoteric setup where your rituals and
what you do enable you to get the power
whereas the Bible is very
simple faith is the substance of things
hoped for the evidence of things not
seen your hope hope is not on a golden
age down here your hope is on a kingdom
that is to come it's the evidence not
seen what is that evidence I go to
prepare a place for you and when I go I
will come again in my father's house saw
many mansions if it were not so I would
have told you are you prepared to
exchange those mansions for this era of
gold that's what's happening the new age
promise is it will be on earth it'll be
here down Earth and that's why the
golden streets all these beautiful
things that heaven is actually yes made
out for that's why Pope Paul I
6 promised that it is man who is the
center of this game and that he will
create this Kingdom on this
Earth but the Lord Jesus said my kingdom
is not of this Earth so M do we have
choice between kingdoms here yes you
have to make one and and why can't it be
silver or brass or iron or clay why does
it have to be
gold I think it is prophetic doesn't the
Bible say come out of a my people yes
and she has written on her forehead
Babylon the great mother of harlots HH
it's really fascinating stuff it's
amazing it's it's actually almost too
good to be true to see this it's a
little bit bone chilling yes it's very
interesting I just wanted to say that
now that you mentioned how this esoteric
and the new age and Christianity should
blend I can understand why you got so
much Flack for doing total Onslaught
well yes because there we talk about the
secret
societies and uh the Masonic societies
specifically mentioned in those
circles because they are an e mancal
movement not within Christianity alone
but with all the religions joined
together in this one great
esoteric setup now what is the center of
it the center of it you shall not die
yeah now if if the center is you shall
not die you are Immortal then what's the
point of Christ dying so that you can
have immortality spare yourself the
trouble I'm Immortal as it is right yeah
so the whole of Christianity the
atonement everything goes out of the
window if man is Immortal and that's F
Satan's first lie that's his first Lie w
yeah now it's wonderful if the when the
puzzle starts getting the puzzle starts
coming together but that's the central
thing they will they will unite on two
things Sunday
sacredness which is an Accolade for the
Sun God and of course the immortality of
the soul and that's spiritism wow
because the Bible says the dead know
nothing right yeah yeah so this is very
very Central but according to blavatsky
and the esoteric world the dead know
everything right that's true and they
will come to Enlighten us and some of
them have become enlightened descended
Masters and that's the and they will
they will become manifesting themselves
again hopefully according to LSA Bailey
this year so maybe down one of these
golden streets who
knows something exciting could happen so
Martin if you want to have everybody on
your side it can't all be negative it
must be something positive as well right
and just import it's important if people
would listen to what we said three years
ago and all of this about the pendulum
can you just explain again
we mentioned there that it will be
pushing so far that people will be
saying enough that's enough and then the
pendulum will swing in the opposite
direction but the tendency of a pendulum
is never to hover around the center no
it's either on the one side it passes
the center but it goes to the other side
right yeah and this is pendulum swing so
everything that was brought in that
doesn't make sense or that this rupt
Society has to be removed so that it
seems not only good to the average
person but particularly also to the
religious world so let's have a look at
what he's all done we have accomplished
more in 43 days than most
administrations accomplished in four
years or eight years and we are just
getting started and I have stopped all
government sense ship and brought back
free speech in America it's back and our
country will be woke no longer we
believe that whether you are a doctor an
accountant a lawyer or an air traffic
controller you should be hired and
promoted based on skill and competence
not race or gender you should be hired
based on Merit and the Supreme Court in
A Brave and very powerful decision has
allowed us to do so thank you thank you
very much and I signed an order making
it the official policy of the United
States government that there are only
two genders male and
female I also signed an executive order
to ban men from playing in women's
sports Common Sense has become a common
theme and we will never go back never
never going to let that happen $8
million to promote
lgbtqi
Plus in the African nation of luto which
nobody has ever heard of $8 million for
making mice
transgender this is real because we are
draining the swamp it's very simple and
the days of rule by unelected
bureaucrats are
over Martin is there anything that
doesn't sound logical there no actually
everything there is something that I can
agree with okay it's interesting the two
gentlemen behind him
are second and third in line for this
Throne yeah right yeah that and all of
them have the same mindset so I not only
assume but according to what they have
stated in the past they are on the side
of
dominionism so this golden age is this
an age when the church also has input
and rules oh for sure because you must
remember the third in line he actually
for 20 years gave lectures on why church
and state should not be
separated so he said it was based on bad
history but this is very fascinating
this is the this is the first time in my
experience as a Christian where we have
this kind of situation where that which
the Bible clearly
foretells can become a reality or
actually is already a reality it's
beginning it's actually I spoke to
somebody uh during the week and I
said it's almost too good to be true you
you're too scared to let to to accept
that this is happening yes and the image
of the Beast is obviously something that
is akin to what the first Beast did and
that was the power of church and state
the spiritual sword of the church yeah
over and together with the secular St
sword of the state enforcing Church
Dogma that was how the first Beast Roman
Catholicism ruled in the middle ages
yeah and image has to do the same and
when we see the image if we see the
glimpses of the abomination of
desolation standing in the Holy Place
written or spoken about by the Prophet
Daniel let the reader understand we're
right
there this guy the second in line is a
Vatican a pre Vatican 2 Catholic that's
very he's a very Storch project 2025
supporter yes and his Hollywood
representative that was appointed isn't
that a prev Vatican 2 individual as well
M Gibson 100% yeah for sure well let's
have a look what else he had to say we
have developed in great detail what we
are calling the gold card which goes on
sale very very soon for $5 million we
will allow the most successful job
creating people from all over the world
to buy a path to us citizenship it's
like the green card but uh better and
more
sophisticated as commanderin-chief my
focus is on building the most powerful
military of the future as a first step
I'm asking Congress to fund a
state-of-the-art golden dome missile
defense shield to protect our homeland
all made in the
USA other places have it and the United
States should have it too right Tim
right
they should have it too so I want to
thank you but it's a very very important
this is a very dangerous world we should
have it we want to be protected and
we're going to protect our citizens like
never
before I believe that my life was saved
that day in Butler for a very good
reason I was saved by God to make
America great again I believe that
[Music]
now it is our time to take up the
righteous cause of American Liberty and
it is our turn to take America's Destiny
into our own hands and begin the most
thrilling days in the history of our
country this will be our greatest ERA
with God's help over the next four years
we are going to lead this nation even
higher and we are going to forge the
freest most advanced most dynamic and
most dominant civilization ever to exist
on the face of this Earth we are going
to create the highest quality of life
build the safest and wealthiest and
healthiest and most vital communities
anywhere in the world we are going to
conquer the vast frontiers of Science
and we going to lead Humanity into space
and plant the American flag on the
planet Mars and even far
beyond my fellow Americans get ready for
an incredible future because the Golden
Age of America has only just begun it
will be like nothing that has ever been
seen before thank you God bless you and
God bless America m is almost too much
to unpack
there and it's it what do you think
about this golden stuff the old time
well there's a golden card yeah I could
bring an analogy but I'll rather steer
away for a moment understand and then
there's a golden dome that's very
interesting obviously that's a nuclear
deterrent
Dome and then he is
chosen and we'll get into the chosen a
little while
later for a particular
purpose and if that purpose is to lead
America back to
God then we have to make sure that it is
the right God oh yeah ex is it the God
who created heaven and earth or is it
another God remember when the king of
pamus the last king at Talus
III bequeathed his title and his tests
mhm and his
divinity to the emperor of
Rome then that title pontea
Maximus went eventually to the bishop of
Rome and he not only took the title he
also took Divinity because there are
many many statements where they claim
that the papal head is divine yeah and
has on this place the the the very role
of God God
Almighty Martin is that the god of the
universe or is that another God that's
another God well what is the Seal of God
in the fourth Commandment the Sabbath
the Sabbath says that yve is the creator
of Heaven and Earth and that's his
dominion and the other one says no he
has an Earthly he has an Earthly seat
with Earthly Authority and the mark of
his ecclesiastical power is the
transference of the Sabbath to the
Sunday now who are they following here
which deity are they following is it uh
the Pagan
deity that Babylon used to follow and
remember that the the
Israelites loved to worship that
deity they gave him the name Yahweh but
they gave him the attributes of
baale so that they later couldn't even
distinguish between the one or the other
one anymore and it took the Prophet
Elijah to bring them to their sentence
and say is who's God the one who brings
down fire from heaven he's God but I'm
expecting a little bit of fire from
heaven it's promise first the
counterfeit fire and then unfortunately
the real fire that will sort things out
okay so but if you mean the counterfeit
fire explain a little bit well mon there
many forms of counterfeit
fire uh he will bring down fire from
heaven deceiving men right now that
could be a literal fire that would be
interesting but it could be a spiritual
fire a false Holy Spirit I think we've
seen enough of that in the last few
years so he was
chosen and uh Martin this sounds so it
sounds so mean to say by the fruits will
eventually know is this a repentance a
humility a asking to come back to the
service of God keeping all of God's
Commandments and repenting from all the
evils yes they've banned many of the
things which the world calls evil but at
the same time they are talking about
this
exaltation he mentioned that they will
be the most dominant of all
um
civilizations the greatest civilization
ever yeah now the Bible clearly says
that babyon was the head of gold
yeah and that uh this kingdom was all
encompassing it had control over the
civil and religious elements of that
time period yeah and may last forever is
what uh Nebuchadnezzar said but of
course it didn't last forever or did it
no it wasn't just a while later it was
gone all right but it's still there
because it's philosophy is still there
it's still in this now where do we find
that philosophy only in the first Beast
of Revelation yeah because that Beast
had a the head of a lion and it spoke
with the mouth of a lion obviously now
the lion was the symbol of Babylon so
the Babylonian element never went to way
no but if we take then if he said that
this will be the most dominant um
civilization ever then that is in the
Fulfillment of Prophecy oh sure but
there also not very it's not very
Christlike no I mean no so when you
started off you said that they bring
might bring in some very good things
that they biblical yes but the there's a
Dragon element in there he he starts off
like a lamb body speaks like a dragon
well Martin let's go a little bit more
into some spiritual aspects and see how
the administration is very deeply
involved in those spiritual aspects then
we have to ask ourselves these spiritual
aspects these
elements are they uh in line with
scripture or do they have pagan origins
for example oh for it's very interesting
you mentioned earlier that that's why
actually you put a thought in my a
thought train in my mind when you
mentioned that the esoteric and the
Christian would be starting to blend
yeah we see this in in in in in stuff
like the chosen yes well let's have a
look which is supposed to be a Christian
thing but now all of a sudden you see
all of this they said look and the way
Dallas tells the story about 10 seconds
into the audition he's like that's Jesus
that's my Jesus for this show and so we
did that film and it was screened he
brought me back to to view it like a
month later at the Good Friday service
with his church about seven Services it
was like 15,000 people saw this thing in
a matter of a day and a
half and it was remarkably well received
it was so beautiful and it was it was
the essentially the the foundational
bones of the concept of the chosen which
is this um this sort of ignatian
spirituality this ignatian uh insight
into uh the gospels which is basically
you put yourself in the gospel you a in
the gospels you ask yourself a series of
questions and that's how you meditate on
the gospels through this form of
spirituality and so this this process of
film making was kind of like a a living
example of that on on Celluloid or
digital Celluloid so when you're reading
your scripts when you're preparing yeah
you're basically reading the
gospel yeah gospel plus I'll I'll say
it's you know
because as a TV
show it's not always you know the
scriptures as they are don't always give
us the full picture of a conversation
they definitely don't of a character of
a person so we have to through you know
uh
biblical uh these a group of biblical
Scholars that and advisers that help us
uh and and give insight into the things
that we're writing uh we we H have to
craft these plausible hopefully uh
authentic
backstories that create believable
characters that could have existed in
the first century that um augment the
world that the gospels give us a glimpse
into so a lot of it is scripture yes but
then there there is some creative
license taken just to be able to make a
good TV show cuz at the end of the day
this this isn't this isn't the Bible
we're not saying this is the Bible we're
we have a TV show first and foremost
that is based on the gospels and
hopefully is compelling enough for you
to really you know get hooked into it
and binge it just like you would binge
any other TV show and then start asking
yourself well what what did Jesus really
say did he say these things is this is
this character really like this like let
me I want to explore and then you if you
can get people to read the Bible and
then want to have a relationship or even
Explore what it means to have faith if
you've never had
Faith well Martin the admits quite
blatantly that it is
performed with ignatian
spirituality that is of course Jesuit
spirituality with Vis visualization
yeah and not only that of course in
visualization you project yourself into
into the very situation that you are
depicting and that becomes a
reality and it plays off like a a
theater and then you enact that theater
that's a form of hypnosis by the way
it's a form of self hypnosis and it's a
spirituality that is totally foreign to
the Bible
because the Bible is based on faith on
what God
Said here he plainly says that that is
part of the theme but it is augmented
right the gospel plus yes so he's saying
well what did Jesus really say you was
somebody who said that right in the
beginning he said did God really say
same maybe he said something else right
and I remember I watched the first few
episodes and when I saw the first
incredibly
unbiblical presentations or
representations uh then you know one of
them was when Jesus ran his Sermon on
the Mount past um Matthew and sought
advice whether this was right or that
was right that that totally freaked me
out and I couldn't watch it anymore
because we're talking about Divinity
we're talking about God and the the
words that rolled down through the ages
are of such importance and such weight
that no human could augment them with
any wisdom that they could possibly have
so what it did to me at that stage it
downplayed the glory and the Majesty of
God and
elevated the the human that's exactly
what all the six said he would do it
brings God Jesus down to our level and
not taking us up to understand where he
was so this is Catholic
spirituality so and it is it is the
counterfeit of faith it is 100% Catholic
um spirituality and the reason why it's
important to show this again we did do a
whatsa Prof a while back but a lot of
people came back and said uh it's not
actually what they're saying even Dallas
Jenkins the the he went on and commented
onto another video that was made on it
and said no this is not true but here
roomi comes and he plainly states how
they do those that it's ignatian
spirituality and remember that the
Jesuit order and ignatian spirituality
was to counteract the
Reformation where your salvation is
based on on faith alone and not like in
the joint Declaration on grace alone by
Christ saving Works no by faith alone
and his atoning blood it's a terrible
situation that we have now that true
Christianity has
basically discarded the very
Cornerstone righteousness by faith out
of the
gospel and righteousness by faith Martin
is made manifest by obedience to all of
God's
Commandments otherwise you have no
evidence that you have even appropriated
the righteousness of Christ because
righteousness means doing right and
Jesus said I have kept the law yeah and
not one jot or title will disappear from
the Lord and if you love me then keep my
Commandments and if you say you love me
and you don't keep the Commandments
you're a liar Martin can it be any more
plain than that do you need
righteousness if there's no law so what
is the essence of the third Angel's
message isn't it righteousness by faith
what do we have here we have a
counterfeit we have a counterfeit that
bypasses actually bypasses Jesus Christ
and it's so subtle be I mean if you
watch this the complete um
interview you and I know the people that
watch the series as well they cannot
understand why we carry on and why we
say be careful this is not from God
because it looks so good and it's so it
seems so
elevating but we'll see that it doesn't
stay at this level it permeates all the
way through to government that's it and
then church and state on the same page
yeah so let's continue the reason I
asked the question and you didn't FL
was that I think some people would feel
like that's a pretty heavy role mean
it's Jesus yeah basis of the world's
largest religion yeah God himself
according to Christians did you ever
feel that on you like that's a lot in
the first season I did um there was this
moment especially um which I've kind of
talked about at times
where and it's still I think it still
sort
of affects me I actually like telling
the story cuz it's a
reminder for me to to
remember what it's all about and who I'm
serving as I as I endeavored to portray
this role and so we were about Midway
through the first
season and the time came from for me as
Jesus to start preaching you know um
full-on sermons and we started
filming and then as I was going through
these words I I suddenly it's like I
kind of felt I was outside of myself
listening to myself preached to a crowd
outside the doors of of in our story uh
zebedy James and John's father zeb's
house and there is a crowd of people
that would was growing crowd of of of
onlookers you know and our our wonderful
background actors that participate in
the show and and many of them of whom
have participated for years um they this
crowd starts growing outside the house
as Jesus begins preaching and the
scene's not specifically about Jesus
it's about other stuff that's happening
in the background that becomes the
foreground of the story and in the
background Jesus is preaching but I
still have to preach I still have to say
these lines from scripture convincingly
and and try to Mesmerize and Galvanize
the people that are listening to me and
get their attention and they seemed
really attentive so much so that it made
me really self-aware yeah and and I
thought what am I saying what are these
words like these are holy holy words
said by the holiest being That Ever
Walked the face of the earth I shouldn't
be doing this this this feels wrong and
and so I would have those feelings and
then you know we would stop and then
move on to the next setup and put the
camera in a different place and and then
as it as it went on I I just had to stop
the production for a moment to talk to
the director to Dallas S I said can we
just can we hold can we just slow down a
second and he said what's what's going
on and so we I I took him aside I said
listen man I I'm I'm having a hard time
right now like I was starting to feel
panicked and overwhelmed um almost like
they be I've only had one panic attack
in my life and and it started to feel
like it was creeping into that and I
didn't know what why or how well I kind
of knew I thought I knew why and um and
what was going on but I just said
can we slow it down and he said what's
what's going on and I
said I'm saying these words and it's and
hearing them hearing myself say them I
don't feel worthy to be saying
them you know
Martin
sometimes God does try to impress a mind
right I think so definitely and now as
he himself states there he felt that you
know was it right right for him to speak
these words and take this
role and uh can we do this kind of thing
well it is sort of Jesuit
theater
and uh strictly speaking to take that
role and to enact it even though as he
says the background was more important
than what Jesus was saying that should
never be the case
right the foreground of what Jesus was
saying is more important
now when you are pre preaching when
you're a
preacher then it's perfectly in order to
repeat those words yeah but when you are
acting the
role is it then still right and I think
maybe the Holy Spirit spoke to
him uh he used interesting words such as
Mesmerizing the
people Jesus never mesmerized anyone he
never bypassed your
conscious mind yeah
he never bypassed it it's not mesmerism
that's hypnosis that's exactly it goes
back to all the other things yes so
people were never
captivated by whatever it is that was
mesmerizing them they were captivated by
the weight of the words yeah and how it
struck their Heart cords correct so
there's a big difference you know in
Catholicism Leo deina is very important
important that's sacred reading yeah so
what is important there just like in
Islam it is the tone and the intonation
that you put into it that takes the
center stage that is a shift Martin from
man does not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of the lord it's very subtle
because you're actually using the
Bible but you are
using that which is around it rather
than the essence of the word it's more
important how you pronounce it or even
how you sing it yeah because they would
have the Canton singing it right and
that creates a mystical atmosphere which
is mesmerizing yeah and mesmerism can be
introduced in many ways you can just do
it through the tone or you can do it
through music
when you walk into a
casino there's that mesmerizing Buzz
that's going on it's not really a tune
it's not really anything like that but
it puts you in an altered state of
consciousness so that you lose your
discernment as to how you're going to
spend your money yeah yeah and so when
you're going to a church it's taking you
away from having your conscience
thinking no it what what the point is it
can look very good yeah because you're
actually using the words right
but let's have a look where it leads to
what's it like for you to be recognized
on the street for playing
Jesus I know just from having dinner
with you last night and telling people
you were coming here there's a lot of
intensity like you're I've been on
television for 30 years I've never
experienced anything like what you
experienced for example is in my house
last night people are very intense when
they see you it's bound up in their
feelings for you but also their feelings
for Jesus what's that like I I give I
give God all the credit I give Jesus the
credit and uh you know like I'm like
like our buddy Russell
Brand like I was once his standing I I I
feel like I'm Jesus's standing Jesus is
the star and I'm his standing because of
who I'm
playing and because there is this often
times this front-loaded
relationship that they already have with
Jesus and then I become standing like
the
face of that relationship that they now
when they read the Bible I've been told
this my face pops into their mind as
they're hearing scriptures or they're
seeing I mean even for myself when the
when I'm at mass and the priest is
reading the
gospel and he's talking about Peter I'm
I'm thinking of Shahar Isaac who plays
Peter in our show and I'm like
okay yeah I can't get him out of my head
and yeah but okay I love Shahara and
he's great as Peter and so yeah it's
just you try even as an artist like you
you you still suffer that you you can't
quite make the separation yeah because
You' you now have this relationship with
these people and these characters and
so to be the face of what is often the
most important relationship in a
person's life I mean even beond their
family it's like God first and then
family and then everything else to be
the face of that four people uh I I
don't often I try not to think about
that yeah it's it's more than being the
sidekick on Seinfeld
yeah I was in confession once myself
when I a guy came out of the
confessional and he recognized me he's
like oh yeah and so he starts talking to
me and then he starts
starts to tell me what he was telling
the priest in the confession I said no
no no no no no you see anything
interesting you keep it in there I
wouldn't let him get that
far no I said that's that's not for my
ears save it for the Confessor so it's
uh I'm not Catholic but I've always
thought that um confession is the
coolest thing they
do it's a it's a gift man it's a life of
course we when it became Psychotherapy
and you put like an atheist with bad
judgment on the couch across from you it
I don't think we lost something do you
know what I mean yeah it's like if
you're a cheesecloth full of holes right
and you go into confession and you
receive the sacrament of of
reconciliation from the priest and the
priest you know we believe he's been
given Divine Authority that has a maybe
a not visible but a tangible physical
metaphysical effect on on the casing of
your soul and it's like mending the
little holes every confession is like
you're you're closing up those holes and
restoring that connection with God in a
way that that
is essentially repairing your soul so
Martin what you
portray to the world is very important
right what is he portraying is he
portraying the biblical way or is
portraying the Catholic way 100% the
Catholic way is the Catholic way
biblical no unfortunately
not all right now Martin they're talking
about the importance of
confessing the Bible says confess your
faults one to another yeah the new
translation says sins strong is there a
difference between your faults and your
sins yes definitely big uh shouldn't one
confess one sins to God only only to
only to God right come unto me all ye
that are weary and Heaven lading it
doesn't say come to me through a priest
by the
way a priest is someone who brings a
sacrifice now Jesus had Forever by one
sacrifice had completed the whole
requirement for the atonement right yeah
he has one sacrifice forever made
perfect so there's no need for a
sacrifice protestantism recognized this
and removed the sacrificial altars out
of the
churches interesting
right and under the Oxford movement in
England they were brought
back and so the Church of England went
back to paganism by
reintroducing the altar now we have a
high priest
who does duty not in an Earthly
Sanctuary but in a Heavenly
Sanctuary but in Catholicism you have an
Earthly priest in protestantism you have
a minister yeah it's not a priest no
it's more like a teacher yes someone
once said to me oh so you think you're a
priest because you know I'm a
preacher so I said uh there's no need
for a
priest because the sacrifice has been
made there was a need for a priest in
the Old
Testament when in a typical fashion you
sacrific the lamb yeah but not in the
New Testament we become ministers we
become servants to others so there's a
lot of things here that are very wrong
it's like a a metaphysical experience he
says he said yeah espe the confession
now what is the metaphysical experience
explain for us please metaphysics that's
the occult
terminology so it is a a feeling of
relief because of a ritual that you have
gone through confessing your sins to a
mortal man with the same faults as you
have and expecting that God must adhere
to the sentence of the priest because
that's what they say in their catechism
that God has to either pardon and or not
pardon as they give Absolution so who's
mightier in this context is it the
priest or is it God the priest the
priest is the mightier one that is
Shifting The Salvation from the Heavenly
to the Earthly it's a very dangerous
subtle concept and you see how dangerous
it is because because of the show and
all of these things there's like Tucker
saying that that's one of of the most
beautiful aspects of Catholicism is the
confession and and then Catholicism of
course has many
rituals yeah many rituals in the old
days they also prescribed many
pilgrimages now
Martin God where two and three come
together they is served yeah you do not
have to go to a spe specific
place in order to get points with God I
don't have to make a pilgrimage to LS or
in the Muslim world to Mecca in order to
to have communication with God on a
higher
level and in my inner chamber where it's
just me and God there we can have a
conversation one onone that's without
any mediator yeah that's where you do
your confession so yes I agree with taka
it is a beautiful gesture but not to a
human being
absolutely absolutely just another thing
that you've just mentioned they've got
the pilgrimage now because it's the holy
Year yes that you can go to through the
and walk through the gate to get an
Indulgence and it's going to overflow
you know that's how Italy keeps itself
afloat with all these pilgrims that come
and spend their money over there now
Martin they're going to talk also in
this interview about Ash Wednesday we'll
we'll pull it through to the government
in a moment but uh it it it again goes
to a Works thing yes conf the point is
which religion is being portrayed
eventually through the government to the
society that's the important thing
they're going to talk about Ash
Wednesday now nowhere in the Bible do
you read about Ash Wednesday uh Ash
Wednesday a day where many mark their
forets with
ashes now that's fascinating a symbol of
repentance is there anything wrong with
repentance no Martin do I have to wear
something to show that I have repented
definitely not I I mean it makes me
think of fasting and the Bible says
don't when you fast don't fast in such a
way that everybody sees that you're
fasting now in the Old Testament you
often read about uh sackcloth right that
people put on sackcloth and Ashes on
their head and stuff like that and uh
many of them did it under their clothes
so that you wouldn't see
it and there's the case of the king that
was walking on the wall right and the
the lady was complaining that she had to
eat her children because of the famine
and he tore his clothes and she saw that
he was wearing sackcloth underneath yes
so there are instances where you know
you can display that you are but that
used to be in the the Old Testament but
Jesus said don't make a show of it don't
make a show of
it and one wonders why we need to
display these things does it does it uh
show something about yourself so here we
have seven celebrities observing lent
and encourage encouraging others to join
and we have the actors there on the left
and we have important person
personalities wearing the ass Wednesday
Mark now what is this portray
protestantism or Catholicism oh 100%
Catholicism but it's paganism also yeah
it draws back to it all the time but
it's it's interesting I don't think well
I I don't remember it ever being so um
popular do you know that the early
Christians
that were in the United States of
America even refused to celebrate
Christmas yeah the Puritans yes the
Puritans interesting and now we're
getting so far as to read this in this
Catholic news agency 5th March uh
article the White House holds Ash
Wednesday mass for
staff so you propagate one thing via the
television and now the government
is setting the
tone so a Catholic mass was reportedly
celebrated for the staff at the White
House today in observance of Ash
Wednesday an email from the White House
management office informed staff that
the mass would take place in the Indian
treaty room at 8:30
a.m. so this is when Christians begin
the holy season of Lent we'll come to
that in a moment
the statement concluded with the
president and the first lady saying let
us prepare our souls for the coming
glory of the Easter Miracle adding May
almighty God bless you and may continue
to bless the United States of
America prior to the election Trump had
extended greetings to Catholics on feast
days taking on social media on September
8th the Nativity of Mary to post happy
birthday Mary along with an image of Our
Lady of gual Lupe now what's interesting
about this happy birthday
Mary do the Protestants understand the
dogma of the Immaculate Conception I
don't I no I don't think they have a
clue you see when you when you just read
the dogma of the Immaculate Conception
automatically your mind is thinking that
Jesus is the one who who's Immaculate
right that's it that's how Protestants
that's how a Protestant would interpret
that but that's not what it
is this is Mary who was born without sin
immaculately so that she could bring
forth the redeema so that is the dogma
of the Immaculate Conception which was
declared ex cathedra infallibly by the
pope just explain what is INF mean that
be without making a mistake you cannot
be faulted so that's like God it's like
God speaking only God is infallible so
that already takes the prerogative of
God right and he declares that
Mary was born
Immaculate she was spared the problems
of original
sin now Martin there's something wrong
with that because the Bible said she was
born under the law
now when the Bible says she was born
under the law that means she was born
under the condemnation of the law and
the condemnation of the law is death the
wages of sin is death so she was born
like anybody else that's what the Bible
says now if God could declare Mary
Immaculate without a
sacrifice yeah then couldn't he do it
for you and for me I would Pro protest
could wouldn't that mean that Martin
that the cross is obsolete yes because
God by decree can declare someone
Immaculate and faultless that's it
that's why the Quran denies the
atonement as well and says Allah is all
powerful he doesn't need the Shad of the
cross in order to
declare uh you capable of going to
heaven he just has to do it by decree
now here in cathol ISM you have exactly
the same thing God decreed that only
Mary should be declared Immaculate but
the Bible says she was born under the
law under the condemnation of the law
therefore she required the sacrifice
just as much as you and I yeah yeah so
this is pushing Catholic Doctrine
definitely which is paganism and look
where it's pushed right in and she's
called the Queen of Heaven yep because
having been declared Immaculate of
course there's no point in her
dying of course because the wages of sin
is death right so she had to have an
assumption she had to go up to heaven
yeah so the Roman Catholics preach that
she ascended into heaven without seeing
death although if you go to some of the
denominations there are Graves of Mary
in Jerusalem yeah and in other places
for that matter
but the point is Martin this is paganism
at its best and if she's there declared
the Queen of
Heaven then she's Isis yeah the goddess
that's paganism so Martin here we have
the White House honoring all of these
Pagan rituals and
ideologies without being aware of what
they are doing I'm not condemning them
in this sense I feel sorry that they
haven't studied this thing through yeah
and church and state separate means that
you are not going to indoctrinate the
public in one particular direction which
is exactly what they're doing yeah for
sure so who are they honoring are they
honoring protestantism or they honoring
the first Beast are they honoring
Catholicism yes definitely aren't they
doing it before
him so Vance receiv ashes at
border and Martin this is fascinating so
he has the vice president of the United
States of
America receiving the ashes so he's
propagating that he is involved in this
na he did this in his private capacity
yeah then vice president JD V would be
showing that he is a faithful Catholic
but this is this is a a government issue
because it's pushing it it's pushing it
so video footage published by cpan
Wednesday shows V practicing Catholic
receiving ashes on the foret from a
Catholic priest before departing Texas
on
Wednesday Vance wasn't the only member
of the Trump Administration to observe
Ash Wednesday which marks the beginning
of the Christian season of
Lent very
interesting president Donald Trump and
first lady Melania Trump published a
joint message to Mark the occasion so is
the government involved at this level at
the highest level at the highest level
so let's continue this discussion and
see what this is all about what is
Lent lent is begins today begins today
is 40 days of uh prayer fasting and
almsgiving leading up to to Good Friday
the Friday before Easter the day Jesus
Christ died on the cross and gave his
life for Humanity two days later 3 days
later we say if you include Friday
Easter Sunday Jesus resurrected from the
dead and original sin uh on uh you know
on the the stain on mankind is lifted
through our belief in Christ and so uh
lent you know for me lent is is a time
to I think simplify and it's a time to
sacrifice and it's a time to draw myself
closer um through You Know the Way of
the Cross basically the theme of how's
pray 40 challenge this year is called
the way and it's the way of surrender
you know the the way of of Christ
basically um and and everything that he
did uh leading up to his passion death
and Resurrection is something for us to
meditate on in that 40 days
typically we try
to we try to make some sort of
meaningful sacrifice some people say oh
it's the time to give up chocolate well
if if Chocolat is chocolate is uh
something that gives you joy and
happiness then yeah that might be a good
thing for you to give up for 40 days and
it can be really hard for some people
like me it' be coffee uh for some people
it's alcohol for some people it's cigars
or cigarettes so you wonder like is
there a connection between like eating
and spiritual awareness clearly there is
is there a connection between overeating
and spiritual
dullness maybe there is and if you wake
up and everyone's fat which is true
including me from time to time so I'm
not judging
um there's just there's like a spiritual
component there now or am I like well I
mean it's a crazy so suggestion one of
the seven deadly sins is gluttony yeah I
mean there's no doubt it one of the most
striking things about having grown up
and living in the modern West is
realizing things later in life that are
like glaringly obvious and you think to
yourself like how did I not notice that
of course Glutton is bad and if the body
is truly a temple of the Lord a
reflection of of the creation and of the
Creator God and you're hurting yourself
then it's like it's an affront to God
which is why things like gluttony are
sinful because but it also dulls you
it's like a b head or you know three
beers or something it like keeps you
from experiencing anything beyond
yourself kind of yeah yeah you're you're
you're now creating a a wall around the
ability to be to
be uh connected to from from the Divine
you know it's like you're Walling
yourself off from from God anyway it
puts cheesecloth over your that's
right you know what I mean I love that
you used food as a reference to just
thinking of like something that kind of
dulls the camera and makes the the edges
softer and you sort of don't fully
perceive what's happening Ian you eat
two Big
Macs um you know you're not as aware of
anything oh my gosh it's like talk about
comos you're just it's a head injury
right yeah 100% And so fasting is the
opposite you're hyper aware that's right
and your mind is just like
you you you sense
everything well Martin there we have
quite a
mouthful and 40 days did Jesus fast for
40 days Martin yes food and water from
all right yeah I almost got the feeling
they were on the point of giving the
health message yeah that's why I put it
in there
because few people realize how spiritual
diet is yes all right so having two Max
is something that veres on gluttony and
head injury now Martin is it good enough
if you want to serve God and you believe
that your body is the Temple of the holy
spirit that 40 days we'll do it and the
rest of the
300 20 odd days 25 days you can then go
back to what is normal or is honoring
your body a choice that is
lifechanging I believe in the letter it
must be a lifechanging and a lifestyle
okay so what does the Lord really want
doesn't he want a contrite heart is this
the fast that I have wanted it's please
elaborate on that again because that's
what God asked in the Bible that's what
he asked yes so what what is the point
of fasting fasting obviously plays a
role
you want to cleanse yourself you want to
clear yourself but you don't want to
hang it as a shield to say hey man I'm
fasting didn't Jesus you refers to that
say when you fast don't you know go
walking around with a long face and
saying this it's a private issue between
you and God I believe that as well yeah
and a 40-day fast period to me is trying
to emulate what Jesus did already for
me I believe my whole life must be a
fast of not doing that which is harmful
to my body not just for a short period
of time and it is basically something
which they claim you know will bring you
closer a fast certainly can bring you
closer now let's take another fast yeah
Ramadan yes yeah okay they also have a
fast and it's also about 40 days Etc so
it's a system that runs through not only
one religion M and uh the interesting
thing about that the fast only lasts in
the daytime when the sun sets the fast
is over and then there's a feast yeah
then then it's gluttony then it's
gluttony and uh I don't know whether
that actually serves the purpose in the
lent Feast then normally meat is is
excluded flesh foods but fish is
permissible so I see that many of the
the fast food chains are now serving
fish Burgers to accommodate everybody
that is involved in
Lent and Martin this is this is
something to me that is an
enactment of something that Jesus did
for
me and is showing that you know you want
to you want to get closer Etc and It's
associated with this Ash Wednesday
that's this beginning of the lent period
it's a ritual can I be saved by a ritual
no and your fruits should constantly
after the 40 days show still go on that
should the day that you are
baptized you become a new person yeah
you put away those things which are
harmful to your body and uh your
relationship is a personal relationship
not based on a pilgrimage not based on a
particular period I mean even uh Rick
Warren talked about 40 days of purpose
yeah what is this with 40 days I would
like to have 365 and a quarter days of
purpose I agree with you 100% because
otherwise it's just focused for a
certain time and then and and what's
interesting is that he mentioned that
that that you
like you should give up now I don't
doubt this sincerity no for sure I don't
this is not an attack on anyone personal
no we don't doubt the the sincerity at
all but the fact of the matter is that a
government is taking this particular
aspect of a
religion and propagating it yeah and TV
now that is
contrary to the constitution in my
opinion I agree now seeing that we spoke
about Ramadan and the Muslims as well
let's have a look at what uh King
Charles had to
say yeah well you good to be with you
but um you bought up King Charles and um
it's interesting it highlights a really
important thing that's going on between
Islam and Christianity the Monarch is
traditionally a def the defender of the
faith and that faith is Christianity but
King Charles kind of evolved that um
statement that that term to Defenders of
the faiths plural meaning all faiths but
I think he doesn't really understand the
theology I mean Islam um believes that
Christ is merely a prophet and not a
Divine Incarnation and to think of
Christ as a Divine Incarnation which is
the centerpiece of Christianity is
blasphemy and unless you're a liberal
Muslim quite open-minded Muslim for most
Muslims it's a blasphemy so I don't
think King Charles understands the
theological confrontation and conflict
between Christianity and Islam and I
think what's happened is Islam and
Christianity religion in general has
been racialized and what I mean by that
is Islam is seen by the liberal Elite in
particular as being the religion of
brown people and Christianity in return
is seen as the religion of white people
now we all know that religion um sorry
the left doesn't really have principles
what they have is a higher of minorities
and at the top of that hierarchy is the
brown man and so therefore Islam what
we're seeing is Islam being um um
getting special privileges and
Christianity effectively being sidelined
and that's what we saw with King Charles
we saw him um packing dates into for for
the ifar celebrations for for ending
Ramadan we saw him um and having a
prayer session at winds a castle but at
the same time not a single mention about
Ash Wednesday about Len
about Christianity in general we have K
starma our prime minister who addresses
a whole Muslim congregation saying that
this Ramadan time is particularly
difficult for you because of what's
going on in Gaza but at the same time
not mentioning anything about
Christianity or indeed the slaughter of
Christians across the world and so there
is a two-tier religious system that
seems to be going on and it's quite sad
to see that Christianity in the Church
of England which should be really the
kind of strength and the backbone of a
of a Nation um is actually been
sidelined and almost rushed under the
carpet because it's fashionable it's
diversity is our strength to promote
Islam and and and and and Muslims in
general well let me make it quite
plain uh I don't agree with him when he
brings it down to a racial level that
Islam is the religion of color and the
other one is the religion of
non-color the issue is far deeper than
that yeah Prince Charles made it quite
plain that he doesn't want to be the
defender of the faith he wanted to be
the defender of Faith yeah now he
pluralized it and said Faith well which
is the same thing faith in
what it is well known that uh Prince
Charles when he was still Prince Charles
went around uh in the attire of Muslim
moms even identifying with the Muslim
faith and with the other faiths and that
has nothing to do with him playing a
race card that has to do with his
Masonic Roots because the entire royal
family is steeped in masonry yeah and uh
masonry teaches that all religions lead
to the same
source and therefore it is a
ecumenical uh setup
and of course that would put Jesus in at
the same level as any of the other
founders of the other religions they
would take him down a notch from being
the Divine Creator God to being just a
prophet exactly and the devil would be
quite happy with that but uh Jesus
Christ is God because the Bible said in
the beginning was the word and the Word
was with God and the word was was God he
came to his own and his own received him
not it's a very sad State of Affairs
that we have there Thomas Falls at his
feet and he says my Lord and my
god with by him were all things created
and without him was not anything created
this is there's a vast difference there
so when you play these games Martin then
you are merely demonstrating your
esoteric roots that comes back to what
you be started off with correct because
masonry at its heart is the worship of
Lucifer it's another deity and as far as
um The Chosen is concerned we know that
many of the advisors that are around
them are Mormons and Jesuits yeah now if
those are the
advisors then what do you do with
statements like uh through the gift of
sin man can have joy that was Joseph
Smith's or that the devil told the truth
about the godhead yeah and he wouldn't
have mother Eve Miss eating the bitten
fruit for anything that's glorifying
Lucifer not glorifying Jesus Christ if
you don't understand those deeper
meanings then you you will not see the
deception and room is a Knights of Malta
so yes well Donald Trump declares
himself king after striking down New
York congestion PR s now it's probably a
bit tongue and cheek but it's still
interesting and uh you have this Trump
over there this poster in This Time
Magazine uh format there long live the
king yeah he actually brought this out
and these videos that were brought out
now I know that they were satire videos
but uh he imely appropriated them to
himself yeah we'll talk about that in a
moment
days after suggesting that he is above
the law Donald Trump declared himself
King following his administration's push
to strike down new tolls for Manhattan
Etc well this is a pretty Liberal oh yes
source of course the White House's ex
account then shared his statement with a
mock cover of Time Magazine featuring a
portrait of the president wearing a
crown with the caption long live the
king
of course we all know that the
presidents all have Royal Blood and he
definitely has Scottish blood if I'm not
yes so they go back to the Kings anyway
so he can he can say that tongue and
cheek and he wouldn't he wouldn't be
lying and it's biblical yes the kings of
the world will give their power unto the
Beast and then it also says that Trump
suggested that he's Above the Law
because uh he's quoting basically
Napoleon who said he who saves his
country does not violate any law then
you are basically Above the Law so he
appeared to quote Napoleon bonapar by
way of rod stiger on Saturday afternoon
after his Blitz Creek of executive
actions and threats to federal agencies
under elong musk were challenged in
court across the country raising alarms
that his administration is preparing to
shred court orders and ignite a
constitutional crisis he who saves his
country does not violate any law the
president wrote on Truth social and X so
he did quote
Napoleon was Napoleon one of those who
opposed himself to the prophecy of
Daniel and said he would unite Europe
yes and Hitler was indeed didn't he do
the same exactly the same we're getting
into real fur prce territory interesting
right add conservative Trump critic Bill
Crystal referencing executive Authority
Under Nazi Germany granting the word of
the fura above
all well
Martin it would speak like a dragon it's
not yet speaking like a gra Dragon it
says Free
Speech but from what I see that free
speech is subject to the common good and
for sure and subject to what they want
you to say all right why would Marco
Ruby the Secretary of State depict
himself with an Ash Wednesday
Mark has that something to do with
honoring the first
Beast unfortunately I well don't know
protestantism definitely not definitely
not definitely not and it's amazing
you're talking about a well supposedly
Protestant country yes and there's
anything but Protestants everything is
honoring the first piece they're doing
exactly what the Bible said they would
do I want to put up on the screen truth
social earlier today president Trump
release all the hostages now not later
immediately return all the dead bodies
of the people you murdered or it is over
for you only sick and twisted people
keep bodies and you are sick and twisted
I am sending Israel everything it needs
to finish the job not a single Hamas
member will be safe if you don't do as I
say I have just met with your former
hostages by the way I ran into them in
DC as well their stories are harrowing
uh whose lives you have destroyed this
is your last warning for the leadership
now is the time to leave Gaza while you
still have a chance also the people of
Gaza a beautiful future awaits but not
if you hold hostages if you do you are
dead make a smart decision release the
hostages now or there will be held to
pay later wow now uh I guess that's
pretty clear and unambiguous and I think
both of us know president Trum Trump
well enough he means it what's going to
happen yep well I hopefully that they're
going to do exactly what he just said
you know how long we've been waiting for
a long time in this country to have the
kind of leadership with that kind of
clarity people get don't realize the
president meets with these people he
hears their stories he's outraged and
rightfully so he's tired of watching
these videos every weekend where
hostages that are emaciated are released
and bodies are turned over and sometimes
it's the wrong bodies and this five here
and three there and the games that are
being played and he's lost his patience
with it he's been very clear about this
from the beginning he's created space
and time for this to be solved and now
it's time for seeing it come to an end
it's enough of this already these people
have been in captivity now for over a
year and a half these are monsters it
needs to stop and and you I I wish there
were more International pressure along
the same lines here but I'm glad he's
putting those statements out I think
he's he doesn't say these things and not
mean it as folks are finding out around
the world if he says he's going to do
something he'll do it he'll do it it and
so they better take that
seriously
Martin which country in the world is the
mightiest country in the world at this
stage is America the US are you fooled
as well
yes well Martin with that sign on his
forehead that's the isn't he saying that
the Vatican is the most powerful nation
in the world they just the executive arm
of right the most now the Vatican
doesn't have an army except the little
Swiss God that's sitting around there in
their little suits but uh they have a
general yes and they have Knights which
are called the Knights of Malta and the
Knights of Columbus and the Knights of
this and the Knights of that and the
Knights of the other right yeah yeah so
they have an
army and are these people their army for
sure for sure right you can I was just
thinking um
it's all like we mentioned before the be
everybody is celebrating the beast's um
celebrations absolutely and then they
come here and what I was just thinking
is
that we we've been accused for of
fear-mongering yes but the if they sh
they are showing you glimpses of the
power that they will use
if you go against what they want you to
do like the previous presidents like
woodro Wilson for already said that
there is a power so
subtle so secret that you dare not speak
about it above a whisper right and the
amazing thing is that he was speaking
against them these guys are elevating it
now this is very interesting now this
statement that we just heard about in
this video so we don't have to read the
whole thing it's just if you don't do
what you're told you're dead right and
the the picture that he has posted there
of himself or that's also in the white
house
now what does that indicate does this
mean resolve you will do as I say I have
the power this was his Muk shot in when
he had to go to prison or not to prison
but when he had to go to the police
station yes and he's using it because
that face is telling
you exactly where you stand now Martin
he doesn't only say these things he has
the power to execute them yeah the other
day he said to Russia if you don't start
playing ball you will start getting
sanctions like you cannot believe he's
wielding that
power and then he says that once this
situation has been resolved he will
rebuild Gaza
[Music]
right
Shin Shin
it was very tongue and cheek but it
seems that Donald Trump liked it no he
enjoyed it for sure he enjoyed it and
did you notice that statue that was gold
from top to bottom yes hey Martin it's
that's why is that the kingdom of
Babylon oh for sure and the it's
um Balloons with his face with golden
everything is gold golden cards golden
domes golden
age and a
king he called him yeah I mean the
greatest age ever isn't he clothing
himself with gold from top to bottom
definitely King Nebuchadnezzar and
building the greatest didn't didn't
Nebuchadnezzar also say isn't this the
great Babylon that I have built yes
exactly and that's why he put up the
golden image
correct now Nebuchadnezzar was a great
Builder and Donald Trump is known for
his building project it's the same it's
interesting that all of those Mighty
Kings were known for their great
building projects that's true like uh
Ahab for example nrod was even nrod but
Solomon was was a great Builder that's
interesting and the
Masons take it of course in his apostate
time and make those twin pillars their
twin pillars fascinating stuff but we
haven't got time to go into all of that
we had eight hours to test some new
technology and we said okay let's let's
do a statement on the Trump Gaza idea
and it was a SAT internally um we wrote
it quickly um and you know there is his
history do you regret making the video
seeing the reaction that it has had
subsequently I mean NBC news showed it
to people inside of the Gaza Strip and a
lot of Palestinians were taken back by
seeing it were upset saying it doesn't
even represent our culture do you regret
posting it
well I regret that this video was posted
maybe in without a
context I you know now now looking
backwards you know it's definitely
created a social conversation whether
about Trump Vision or not um I think
also about Ai and creativity about AI
because you know in the end of the day
if you thinking about any idea and you
created an IP and you're creating
something um you don't expect somebody
to publicize it at least without your
permission or with the context or with
the credit so we didn't get any of that
so you know right now you talking to me
it's actually you know it's something
that makes us at least have a voice out
and explain that that was an internal sa
satire that was not intended to be shown
anywhere Martin if it was a satire then
why was it not intended to be shown
anywhere that doesn't make quite sense
there's a few things that doesn't make
sense of what they're saying I think
it's a lot of propaganda on this one or
not Trump displayed it it it went where
it wanted because uh that's how he feels
for sure yeah now the Israel news says
that Trump's Gaza plan is the final task
before the
Messiah would you find that interesting
well I did definitely when I when I read
this
article so Rabbi fish a respected Mystic
Rabbi yeah Martin are we seeing a lot of
mysticism here that's why I was actually
taken back with what you started off
with and telling that the esoteric and
the Christianity is blending because you
see it all over now Judaism in many of
its forms here is actually not Orthodox
at all it's cabalistic yeah and the
cabala takes us all the way back to the
esoteric Mysteries so it's all interl
with
masonry and uh so what Alicea Bailey
predicted that this great Universal get
together would be coming together this
is exactly what we are
seeing now this Mystic Rabbi from
Jerusalem who titles a Torah blog praed
Trump's plan and predicted that its
success was
inevitable it's interesting right this
is like a new age everyone is focused on
Gaza but that is only one part of the
end of day's agenda which has the Jews
living in Israel's prophesied border
Martin that is a Jesu agenda yeah it is
a Jesuit agenda and it was made a
reality through Rothchild
money and implemented by Masonic order
that
whole country
yes so the Torah explicitly includes
Gaza what Trump is doing is cleaning out
Gaza of all the haters of Israel they
cannot be in Israel after the Messiah
comes is there a religious connotation
to this the whole time that's why I say
it's new age and religion the whole time
right through to the top now just take
your mind back to his previous term
didn't they print his head on the
shackle on the quarter shackle along
with Cyrus yes along with cus the great
so he's the Savior right so the stage is
near nearly set for the Messiah mtin
this is this is a
religiously
orchestrated occurrence yeah the whole
issue it's a takeover of a religious
power which one are they
propagating the Beast R Roman Catholic
Roman Catholicism the Messiah needs
someone to takes care of this oh he's so
helpless right we must really help him
so he said in in his Congress speech
yes and he's the one Donald Trump is the
one that's what they're saying Trump is
merely carrying out the final tasks
needed before Messiah is revealed Rabbi
fish said so they're waiting for the
Millennium yeah now there are two
thoughtss on the
Millennium that is the state of Israel
ruling the world MH right in the
beginning is a bit of a conflab with the
with the Antichrist etc etc in that
theology which is of course not biblical
and then you have the Christian concept
of the church
ruling forever and ever and ever that's
a millennialism that's the Roman
Catholic official View and that's the
one that you can see is being pushed
here yeah the all these this Golden Age
correct that is 100% that that's being
pushed and then they want to build the
temple oh yes that's the ultimate
blasphemy because it negates the
sacrifice on the cross right they're
waiting for a messiah to come yeah so
Jesus was not the Messiah that's one ex
and the waiting the one they're waiting
for is a national deliverer and not a
deliverer from sin so they need the red
heer want to turn now to the long range
picture of what's happening in Israel
and what some say is a sign of the end
times here years ago the arrival of five
red heers in Israel attracted Global
attention today those cows are in
ancient Shilo cbn's Christmas explains
the significance of the historic event
Jewish tradition maintains that the red
heer ashes are needed to rebuild the
Third Temple some Christians believe a
third Temple would pave the way for the
end times even Hamas reportedly blame
the red heers in part for their Invasion
on October 7th because the aloa mosque
would be in danger if the heers were
used to build a third Temple the animals
are also mentioned in the Book of
Numbers Chapter 19 then the Lord spoke
to Moses and Aaron saying this is the
statute of the law which the Lord has
commanded saying speak to the sons of
Israel that they bring you an
unblemished red heer in which there is
no defect in on which a yoke has never
been mounted and you shall give it to
Eleazar the priest and it shall be
brought outside the camp and be
slaughtered in his presence to be
selected these qualifications must be
met be an adult cow with reddish brown
hair no hairs of a different color no
blemishes and never used for any other
purpose these are the five red heers out
here in Shilo two have already been
disqualified but you only need one to
qualify for the ceremony for the
purification for the temple Larry
barager a farmer from northern Indiana
takes care of them it's just a lot of
fun to be involved in something that I
see God is doing behind the scenes he
says what he's experienced since
arriving here is remarkable while I've
been standing here at Shilo every
continent countries I never heard of
before were here to see the red heers
there's something happening in sheilo
and bar Swagger believes it's biblically
significant ideas are becoming a reality
in other words idea of a red haer has
been in the Jewish understanding for
over a couple thousand years but here at
Shilo just
like it says in Genesis
49 there's something happening here
that's drawing the Nations
and it's the red haers this area is
where Hanah prayed for a son where
Samuel serve the Lord and Joshua divided
the land between the 12 tribes the place
where many stories of the Bible occurred
and today we also have the red heers
which is something new the budgets for
this Visitor Center stopped because of
the war so we invite whoever wants to be
partner with us to help this very
important thing of the red head first
sheilo has so much significance it was
the spiritual capital of Israel for 369
years during our visit Bible teacher Dr
Todd Fink brought his group to see the
red heers this is huge this is huge and
the one gal that we that was giv us the
tour she said that part of the reason
why Hamas invaded is because of these
red heers and according to prophecy
these red heers are significant from the
time of Israel's history they say that
only nine have been killed for these
ashes and so for these to be here and
sheilo here and for that to fit in with
what appears to be prophecy on the
horizon we're living in Monumental days
unbelievable times Martin the red heer
is of course a type of
Christ unblemished and he's unblemished
and he's red the color of the sacrifice
of his blood and he was sacrificed
outside the gates where Jesus was
sacrificed and then the temple which is
a spiritual temple built up in Christ
can be erected they totally miss the
symbolism and go back to type whereas
antitype has already come yeah it's
interesting how many like he mentioned
people from across the world even
countries that they haven't even heard
of go to visit this so it's not
something small there's a lot of people
that actually put their faith in it now
Martin this is very important let's just
go back to this m
in true
Catholicism nobody could be saved if you
weren't subject to the bishop of
Rome prev Vatican 2 there was no such
thing as separated
brethren right the Council of Trent
ruling was the one that
was the doctrine of the Roman Catholic
church so Vatican 2 was seen by many as
an Enlightenment but of course not one
single Doctrine was changed it was a
ruse it was a
lie so behind it were Carana and of
course uh and Benedict who was ringer
before he became Benedict they were the
movers and shakers together with the
Jesuits that that organized it and they
referred to all the others religions and
the Christian Protestant as separated
brethren
so no longer damned through Eternal
damnation now prior to that they had all
been subject to Rome now they had
separated through Vatican 2 they could
come back to Rome yeah and be subject to
Rome so in the chter ecumenica you sign
that you accept the pope as primate then
you're no longer a separated
individual and Rome says she will not
suffer loss of children her children
will return to her and they they have
yeah so that part of the prophecy has
been
fulfilled so M if all the children are
back and all the other religions
acknowledge the papal system as
primate can't you switch back to Vatican
prev Vatican 2 times yes where where the
Catholicism is the only religion whereby
you receive salvation by acknowledging
it and that they've got various ways of
implementing it and getting everybody
back there okay so now what kind of
religion does the the hierarchy of the
Trump Administration portray as we said
before post Vatican 2 or prev Vatican 2
prev Vatican 2 now Pope Francis he
excommunicated uh this bishop
veano and now the same individual is
asking Trump's CIA director to
investigate the Deep state plan to
eliminate Benedict V 16th because
Francis took over from him right so many
believed that the true Pope was really
Benedict and Francis was a usurper yeah
now Pope Francis is on the way
out uh will the true church show its
colors again there is no salvation
outside of the Catholic church but not
in the sense of having to be become
Catholic now but acknowledging the
supremacy that's enough that's it what's
interesting is that they call especially
guys like vgo they call the current
church under Frances is also a deep
state or deep church so so must that be
cleansed as well it must be cleansed as
well so that the pendulum actually
inside of this church is also swung and
now has to be it has to swing to the
right it was on the left now it has to
swing to the right and then Martin once
that is acknowledged then who is a if
you acknowledge the
authority then Martin you are doing the
bidding of that Beast yeah and that's
exactly what Revelation says the second
beast is going to do so are we close to
the close of all events yeah it will be
very interesting to see what how it will
be play out in the near future
especially if um Francis will will not
be there anymore and I think it will be
somewhere in going much more to the
conservative and pratic Church of course
because Rome has never rescinded the
Council of
Trent but they don't have to play the
Council of Trent card anymore because
Protestants have already
capitulated they've already made a joint
declaration
and a lot of the argument There Was You
Know tradition I mean the whole of
America is e eating fish Burgers now so
there's no need to argue the point
people just don't know that they've
subtly gone back exactly to the Council
of Trent position so the Deep state
within
Catholicism those that pretended to be
liberal let's put it that way will they
give way to the more conservative wave
and people won't even know that power
has been given unto the Beast again and
then maybe with the same words that
Trump addressed Gaza and Hamas he will
be addressing those that are going
against what this Beast wants you to do
yes so he actually says here in this
last
section that uh the entire ruling class
of the Roman Catholic Church basically
is subservient to the globalist elite
actually the other way around it's just
made to appear like this that's what I
mean
so so Val asks the question needless to
say these activities have nothing
Catholic about them or he makes the
statement and the Abate preaching
religious instruction the care of Souls
and the celebration of the sacraments
are not of the least concern for these
Temple merchants and that's not talking
about the people in the church in the
Catholic Church the leaders so they went
to purging of the church as well yeah
now Trump just had a purging the church
will have a purging and then
Martin we can go home I hope this all
this all will start playing out because
I'm 100% with you this must get done now
that we can go home so in other words
Revelation has the
probability and if you want to be
skeptical the possibility
of being fulfilled in front of our eyes
so Martin is the writing on the wall yes
can you read it if you've got the
prophet yes let's think about
that heavenly
father if this is the writing on the
wall we would like to be able to read it
because it means that there must be a
preparation of the heart to meet the one
whom it is impossible to please without
faith
and works do not even come into this
equation so I pray Lord That You Will
Open the Eyes of
many and that they will come out of her
your people come out of her that they
receive not of her plagues this is my
prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]